[Aplausos]
[Música]
si os pregunto por Suiza Seguro seguro
que muchos automáticamente pensáis en
cosas como bancos joyas o cajas fuertes
la reina de los paraísos fiscales el
país donde el dinero nunca duerme el
sitio donde la cuenta bancaria es mucho
más importante que la propia comida me
equivoco seguro que no y eso que
últimamente las cosas han cambiado mucho
sí sí Suiza ya no es la que era para
poder Acceder al mercado común la
confederación helvética ha tenido que
hacer un montón de concesiones por
ejemplo modificar por completo La
legislación sobre secreto bancario
reformas que lógicamente han tenido
consecuencias
[Música]
quizá ha ido progresivamente perdiendo
posiciones en alguno de los rankings que
nos sirve para determinar el grado de
libertad económica de un país sí Suiza
sigue teniendo impuestos muy bajos y
sigue siendo el segundo país del mundo
en libertad económica según el ranking
de las élite foundation pero si nos
fijamos en la regulaciones ya no resulta
un destino tan paradisíaco de hecho el
país ha ido cayendo progresivamente en
el ranking deam business del Banco
Mundial hasta alcanzar el puesto 36 que
ocupa actualmente Y es que para poneros
en contexto estaba en el puesto 19 en el
año 2008
[Música]
A ver no nos equivoquemos los suizos
siguen teniendo y ofreciéndole al resto
del mundo una de las mejores redes de
seguridad jurídica para las inversiones
el ahorro o simplemente para depositar
las riquezas y no solo estoy hablando de
dinero
Suiza es un paraíso del esquí una
potencia industrial y un importante
centro tecnológico pero sobre todo es
una gigantesca caja fuerte dinero obras
de arte joyas prácticamente de todo sin
ir más lejos aquí en visualpolitik
hicimos un vídeo sobre Suiza y la
Industria del arte os dejo el enlace y
la descripción y luego pues que os voy a
decir todo el mundo se fía del franco
suizo en nuestro canal hermano visual
economic ya os hemos contado el porqué
sin embargo como hemos dicho los últimos
años han cambiado muchas cosas no solo
porque Suiza ya no sea exactamente el
país que todos tenemos en mente sino
porque también le ha surgido competencia
hoy en el mundo ya hay países que pueden
presumir incluso de estar recortando la
los suizos terrenos en su actividad
favorita ser el centro de encuentro de
millonarios y multimillonarios de todo
el planeta de hecho podemos encontrar un
país que no solo ya supera suiza en
muchos Campos financieros sino que
además gracias a su localización
geográfica podría llegar a convertirse
en el nuevo Refugio de Las mayores
fortunas del mundo alguna idea de qué
país estamos hablando
321 Exacto Singapur
[Música]
aunque solo sea por la miniatura Seguro
seguro que muchos lo habéis adivinado
Pues bien fijaos la plaza Financiera
Suiza se enfrenta una creciente presión
mundial Hong Kong probablemente superará
Suiza poniendo fin a una racha de más de
200 años de dominio suizo en el sector
de gestión de patrimonio privado
transfronterizo dijo bcg Asimismo
Singapur podría desbancar a Suiza del
segundo puesto en los próximos años Sí
sí lo sé la noticia de estacas sobre
todo a Hong Kong Pero eso eso tiene un
poco de trampa Hong Kong es una
importantísima plaza Financiera
especializada sobre todo en China es
decir su posición tiene mucho que ver
con ser la puerta financiera de entrada
y salida al gigante asiático El caso es
que Suiza ha sido Un refugio para el
patrimonio de las grandes fortunas
durante aproximadamente los dos últimos
siglos coincidiendo pues con la época en
la que occidente era el único espacio
realmente rico pujante y próspero de
todo el planeta Pues bien desde hace
tiempo Singapur se está convirtiendo en
algo muy pero que muy parecido en Asia
un entorno de negocios ahorro e
inversión abierto seguro y sólido
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y ojo que no solo hablamos del dinero de
China y las grandes fortunas de este
país sino también de economías con
expectativas asombrosas para las
próximas décadas países como Indonesia
Malasia o Vietnam todas ellas están en
un palmo de distancia de esta ciudad
estado y por si fuera poco pesos pesados
ya consolidados como Japón o Corea del
Sur además de China también están
relativamente cerca Por tanto la
pregunta es podríamos decir que está
peculiar ciudad estado del sudeste
asiático está llamada a convertirse en
la nueva Suiza De dónde procede toda la
riqueza que entra en Singapur y cuáles
son exactamente los motivos por los que
eligen este lugar Pues bien Vamos a
responder a estas y otras preguntas en
este vídeo así que sin más preámbulo
arranquemos
[Música]
por cierto solo un último apunte Todavía
está en construcción y aún nos quedan
muchos ladrillos por poner pero not news
el nuevo miembro de la familia
visualpolitik Ya está en circulación si
todavía no lo conoces
suscríbete.com es completamente gratuito
de momento hemos comenzado con una
newsletter pero hay mucho más por venir
Nos acompañas
[Música]
El guardián de los dineros
[Aplausos]
Suiza sigue siendo un gran refugio para
la riqueza mundial según de loite en
2020 la industria financiera de este
país gestionó 2,6 billones con b
hispanos de dólares en activos
internacionales y en total esos activos
financieros superaron en 2021 los 4,1
billones de dólares para que os hagáis
una idea esto supone casi un 40% más que
todo el tamaño del sistema financiero de
un país como España un país cuya
población es cinco veces y media más
grande que la de Suiza Pues bien
Singapur Aún está a mucha distancia en
total según el banco internacional de
pagos de basilea su sistema financiero
gestiona algo más de 2 billones de
dólares en activos aproximadamente la
mitad que el sistema suizo Pero eso sí
crece mucho más Singapur se está
convirtiendo a toda velocidad en un
importantísimo centro de la gestión de
patrimonios en Asia y amenaza con
superar muy pronto a la mismísima Hong
Kong Esto es algo que os hemos contado
en varias ocasiones aquí en
visualpolitik el asalton
tradicionalmente el epicentro el corazón
financiero de Asia ha dejado la ex
Colonia británica con perspectivas muy
poco a la huellas
[Música]
ya sabéis al final la seguridad jurídica
que existía antes de que las autoridades
chinas dieran el golpe en la mesa se
saltaran los acuerdos internacionales y
tomaran la ciudad ya no existe o al
menos está desapareciendo a toda
velocidad evidentemente eso es algo que
ahuyenta los capitales y a los
inversores Internacionales tener tu
dinero bajo el control de la República
popular China de sillín te fiarías de
que nunca te metan mano evidentemente No
gracias lógicamente Esto es algo que
afecta a los inversores Internacionales
pero también a los grandes patrimonios
chinos grandes patrimonios que hasta
ahora han utilizado a Hong Kong como una
vía de escape como una caja fuerte fuera
del alcance del partido comunista chino
por lo que pudiera pasar pero claro como
eso ya no es posible o en el mejor de
los casos no está del todo garantizado
toca Buscar refugio en otra parte y
sabéis que este es exactamente el motivo
por el que la industria financiera de
esta ciudad estado está teniendo una
segunda juventud todo apunta que en
pocos años Singapur no solo superará
Hong Kong como principal plaza
Financiera de Asia sino que será el
continente asiático lo que Suiza es al
resto del mundo fijaos
según deloit el volumen del mercado
internacional de Hong Kong es decir el
número de transacciones de acciones
depósitos índices u otras inversiones
creció más rápido que el de Singapur
entre 2010 y 2016 sin embargo luego la
cosa comenzó a cambiar y a partir de ese
último año cayó por debajo del
crecimiento de Singapur entre 2017 y
2020 y la previsión es que las cosas no
hagan más que empeorar sí el sector
financiero de Hong Kong todavía crece
pero su dinamismo ya no es el mismo
Mientras tanto Singapur No para de
crecer
[Música]
ahora bien las inversiones financieras
no son lo único lo que Singapur estaba
esperando para nada también están
llegando de enormes cantidades de dinero
extranjero en forma de inversiones
directas Como por ejemplo la instalación
de empresas o la compra de inmuebles Y
por supuesto como ya os lo estaréis
imaginando uno de los mayores actores en
todo este proceso están siendo
precisamente los capitales chinos la
pandemia amigos aceleró este proceso
pero Hablamos de una tendencia de fondo
según financial Times el número de
Family offices esto es fondos o
plataformas de inversión dedicadas a
gestionar Los grandes patrimonios de
familias concretas ha crecido en
Singapur un 1400% entre 2018 y finales
de 2021 se ha pasado de unas 50 a más de
700 y se calcula que para finales de
2022 esa cifra podría estar en torno a
las 1500 de todas ellas el 40% tendrían
su origen en capitales procedentes de la
china continental de la misma forma tan
solo en 2022 se registraron unas 500
empresas chinas en Singapur Desde allí
dirigirán las inversiones en países como
la India y otros tantos lugares pujantes
de la región
Y si alguien creía que con el fin de la
política covid Cero en China las cosas
se iban a calmar Pues todo apunta que lo
que está sucediendo es exactamente lo
contrario 27 de febrero de 2023 a medida
que China reabre la huida de chinos
ricos a Singapur se acelerará Y es que
fijaos según la consultora partners que
asesora grandes patrimonios a obtener
residencias en el extranjero Singapur
recibió alrededor de 2800 nuevos ricos
en 2022 se convirtió así en el tercer
destino más popular de todo el mundo
tras los emiratos árabes y Australia no
está mal Como apunte Suiza ocupa en este
mismo ranking la quinta Plaza con 2.200
llegadas de ricos extranjeros y amigos
amigas Aunque Singapur no publica la
nacionalidad de los nuevos residentes se
estima que la mayor parte de ellos son
chinos es decir muchos chinos adinerados
le han visto las orejas al lobo durante
la covid y ahora que se puede mover
libremente Pues están apostando por huir
Y sí el lobo es sin fin por si es lo que
estabais pensando
además muchas de estas grandes fortunas
chinas temen que la tolerancia de Pekín
a la hora de dejar salir a grandes
capitales y empresas pueda determinarse
puede incluso que comienzan a restringir
esos movimientos Así que muchos creen
que si no lo hacen ahora puede que nunca
puedan poner a buen recaudo Su riqueza
esto es representativo de las políticas
de la covid y de las limitaciones del
partido comunista chino a la vida y la
libertad de las personas entonces en
preparación para lo peor deben crear una
red de seguridad en el extranjero Joseph
profesor especializado en finanzas y
gobernanza en la universidad de
queensland además otro de los
principales motivos por lo que la
elección de muchas grandes fortunas
chinas está siendo Singapur tiene que
ver precisamente con la invasión rusa de
Ucrania me habéis ido bien con Ucrania
Pero qué demonios tiene que ver Ucrania
con Singapur pues veréis me explico la
desconfianza hacia la visión cada vez
más nacionalista de sillín genera miedo
y muchas dudas sobre que finalmente
termine llevando a cabo alguna acción
gravita igual lo que podría empujar a
occidente y poner sanciones contra china
por eso Muchos chinos están optando por
sitios que podrían ser más neutrales en
lugar de llevar sus riquezas sólo a
Europa o Estados Unidos y Singapur Pues
reúne todos esos requisitos pero claro
El caso es que obviamente todo esto que
os estamos contando también tiene
consecuencias a nivel local
[Música]
por ejemplo los precios de la vivienda
Singapur crecieron un 8,6% tan solo en
2022 y según analista del mercado los
compradores chinos fueron los que más
condominios compraron de entre todos los
compradores extranjeros Y es que claro
al final hablamos de un microestado de
apenas 5,6 millones de habitantes en un
área poco más grande que la ciudad de
Madrid y en la que casi la mitad son
montañas o espacios protegidos con lo
que como os imaginaréis pues no resulta
tan fácil como simplemente ponerse a
construir más y más para adaptarse a la
enorme demanda este de hecho uno de los
grandes problemas de la ciudad pero no
vamos a entrar en mucho detalle porque
sobre esta cuestión Ya hicimos un vídeo
aquí en visualpolitik un vídeo que os
dejo en la descripción pero ahora bien
al margen de esta cuestión que está
ofreciendo exactamente Singapur a los
chinos para que de repente tantos y
tantos estén optando por refugiarse allí
del creciente autoritarismo de Sí pues
fijaos
pues veréis esta ciudad de estado es
particularmente atractiva para los
chinos está cerca de Hong Kong y de la
China tres cuartas partes de la
población local pertenece a chinas por
eso el idioma mandarín se habla
ampliamente Además del inglés con lo que
las barreras lingüísticas y culturales
son muy pequeñas Así mismo Singapur
cuenta con alguna de las mejores
escuelas y universidades de todo el
mundo esto es un factor particularmente
valorado por las familias chinas por
supuesto la ciudad tiene una industria
de gestión de patrimonios muy
desarrollada y para colmo la gran
presencia de empresas chinas en el país
está permitiendo tejer todo un cluster
de negocio chinos
sin ir más lejos by Dance que es la
empresa china propietaria de La popular
aplicación tiktok tiene un importante
oficina en Singapur y de hecho ha estado
apostando por incrementar su peso hasta
convertirla prácticamente en una especie
de segunda sede central my dance la
propietaria de tiktok invertir a miles
de millones en Singapur a lo largo de
tres años planea invertir miles de
millones de dólares y contratar a
cientos de empleados en Singapur después
de optar por establecer allí su sede
regional en el sudeste asiático este es
tan solo un ejemplo de decenas y decenas
que podríamos poner sobre la mesa
porque lo cierto es que singapurs está
convirtiendo también en un gran polo de
empresas tecnológicas especialmente para
aquellas orientadas a las finanzas y es
que claro vamos a ver esta ciudad tiene
infraestructuras tecnológicas de primera
o un sistema educativo top y muy
orientado a las tecnologías de la
información una regulación no demasiado
densa impuestos comedidos y un montón de
empresas financieras vamos que aquí las
intec se mueven Como pez en el agua de
hecho este es quizás uno de los sectores
más pujantes de la ciudad pero no es el
único queréis saber cómo se está
planteando el futuro de este peculiar
estado Cómo quiere vivir su segunda
juventud queréis saber cómo Singapur
aspira convertirse Ni más ni menos que
en el país más rico de todo el planeta
Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
el Singapur que viene
queridos amigos amigas últimamente
Singapur está que lo parte y su gran
crecimiento como centro financiero y
como refugio para grandes patrimonios
está haciendo que el gobierno pueda
plantearse nuevas metas económicas por
ejemplo a finales del pasado año 2022
estableció la estrategia hasta el 2030 y
la pregunta es en qué quiere convertirse
exactamente Singapur pues veréis
partimos de la base de que algunos de
los sectores que actualmente están más
desarrollados en esta ciudad son
actualmente las fintech la biotecnología
y el turismo médico
para que os hagáis una idea de las 100
empresas locales con mayor crecimiento
entre 2018 y 2021 10 son fintech 8 son
de logística y transporte y 7 de energía
y servicios públicos de hecho sólo en
Singapur había registradas 120 fintech
en junio de 2022
Aunque claro Puede que no sepáis a voz
de pronto si esto es mucho o es poco
[Música]
Pues veréis si lo comparamos con las
menos de 10.000 que hay en Estados
Unidos y ojo que es el líder mundial
rápidamente no tenemos cuenta de que son
muchísimas Estados Unidos el líder
mundial insisto en este campo tiene solo
10 veces más a tener 59 veces más
habitantes pero no solo hablamos del
mundo digital Y si os dijera que uno de
los sectores que más está creciendo
últimamente en este micro país es
precisamente el de las manufacturas Y si
además te dijera que este sector es la
gran prioridad para el 2030 Pues sí a
pesar de que Singapur es un sitio muy
pequeño el sector manufacturero esto es
la industria de toda la vida supone el
22% de su pvp para que os hagáis una
idea en España Francia o Reino Unido su
peso viene a ser del 13 el 10 y el 9%
respectivamente de hecho uno de cada 8
empleos de Singapur está Precisamente en
las manufacturas como veis no todos son
grandes rascacielos de bancos y
aseguradoras en Singapur hay muchísimo
más ahora bien si estáis pensando en
fábricas de zapatos o de juguetes ya se
os puede ir quitando eso de la cabeza
[Música]
Singapur está especializada en un tipo
de manufactura muy avanzada y de alto
valor añadido como la electrónica esto
incluye los semiconductores la
ingeniería de precisión los productos
químicos y también la producción de
componentes para la industria
aeroespacial en total las Industrias
avanzadas suponen en torno al 80% de
toda la producción
[Música]
amigos igual que Suiza ha conseguido
crear una industria altamente
especializada Y sofisticada como por
ejemplo la biomédica en Singapur están
consiguiendo Exactamente lo mismo pero
ahora el gobierno pretende ir mucho más
allá y para eso ha creado un plan
específico en el que la robótica y la
Inteligencia artificial juegan un papel
fundamental el objetivo que persiguen es
que con el tiempo los empleos locales de
bajos valor añadido se reduzcan al
mínimo indispensable
la idea no solo es que los empleos de
bajo valor añadidos se reduzcan en
número sino
que tienen se trasladen diariamente
desde el fronterizo estado malasío de
jojor y lo cierto es que van por el buen
camino para que os hagáis una idea en el
quinquenio 2017-2021 la productividad
laboral manufacturera creció una media
del 11,9% al año
ahora bien Por qué creen en Singapur que
tienen que reforzar las manufacturas en
lugar por ejemplo de especializarse
completamente en el sector de servicios
Pues veréis al igual que hicieron los
suizos en lugar de descartar cualquier
tipo de apuesta que esté más allá de los
bancos las aseguradoras o yo que sé la
industria de inversión el gobierno
quiere promover una industria local
fuerte que no esté tan expuesta a los
vaivenes económicos globales es decir la
diversificación de toda la vida Eso sí
en campos de altísimo valor añadido
ya os contamos también aquí en
visualpolitik como Singapur está
haciendo algo muy parecido con el sector
primario el gobierno está impulsando la
creación de granjas hitech por todo el
país os dejo también el enlace del vídeo
en la descripción Pues bien El caso es
que para lograr todos estos objetivos
Singapur cuenta Aparentemente con todos
los ingredientes necesarios una enorme
cantidad de profesionales altamente
cualificados una enorme cantidad de
capital listo para invertir en todo tipo
de proyectos mucha seguridad jurídica e
impuestos comedidos infraestructuras y
comunicaciones top y una larga
larguísima lista de profesionales
inversores deseosos de trasladarse a
este lugar así que ya lo veis Singapur
parece estar a punto de convertirse en
la nueva Suiza con una receta de éxito
muy similar Aunque eso sí evidentemente
actualizada los nuevos tiempos y a su
contexto regional amigos como podéis ver
los suizos todavía son más ricos pero
eso es algo que podría cambiar muy
pronto pero ahora llegados hasta aquí
turno para ti crees que el modelo de
Singapur para atrapar grandes
patrimonios es replicable en otros
países déjanos tu opinión por aquí abajo
los comentarios y hablamos debate y ya
sabéis si este vídeo es resulta
interesante y no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros a visualpolitik Ah
importante y no olvidéis echarle un
vistazo a news.com una vez Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]